[Music]
Nevada California and Arizona say they
will cut their Colorado River water
usage but the details are still kind of
sparse this is an effort of course to
keep the federal government from
imposing the cuts let the states kind of
work it out for themselves eight news
now anchor Kirsten Joyce with what we do
know about the deal Nevada California
and Arizona say they will cut water use
by one and a half million acre feet by
the end of next year it's about 20
percent of the earth combined water use
the deal also says Lake Mead won't be
allowed to drop below 1 000 feet and
it's about 50 feet higher than that
right now not much of those cuts likely
to come from our state which is already
the most efficient water user along the
river we do have the smallest allotment
and only use about 70 percent of that in
total all seven states on the Colorado
River say they will cut their water
usage by 3 million acre feet by 2026
which is about 20 percent of total water
used from the River California is the
river's Lar largest water user its
Headwater Chief says it will be
responsible for half of that amount now
the federal government will give 1.2
billion dollars to the states to use on
water efficiency things like water
Recycling and patching up leaking
infrastructure but it's not known how
much each state will get so why announce
the deal now well in 2026 the 100 year
old agreement that breaks up who gets
how much water will run out Southern
Nevada Water Authority general manager
John Ensminger called this a bridge to
get to 2026 and a new deal
by the way the second largest water user
on the river is Colorado conservation
groups have criticized that Colorado
won't be responsible for cutting its
water usage at all in any of those deals